since the start of this year we've been
watching multiple asset classes sell off
this has hit the stock market hard but
it's also now working its way through
the bond market i'm going to walk you
through what's happening in the markets
and why what this means for investors
and how this new trend could change the
concept of money management a
multi-trillion dollar industry
stocks and bonds are both sinking
because the federal reserve is expected
to begin responding to rising inflation
by raising u.s interest rates higher
rates from the fed means higher rates on
u.s government bonds the u.s government
is one of the most trusted institutions
in the world so when its rates go up
other companies rates have to go up as
well because investors would rather put
their money with the us government but
they'll give it to corporations if it
means they can earn a little more those
higher rates mean lower bond prices so
you're seeing prices sink across the
board higher interest rates also mean it
costs companies more to borrow which can
eat into their future profits and hurt
stock prices so stock prices and bond
prices have been falling at the same
time the market sell-off seems to be
hitting everything because it's all
related when interest rates rise it
makes investors re-evaluate their
choices and consider whether these
companies are worth the incredibly high
valuations they currently have stock
market downturns are actually pretty
normal what's unusual right now is that
investors typically buy bonds in times
like these because they're considered
safe investments but with the fed
raising interest rates bonds are selling
off even the most high quality issues
which are considered to carry
historically low risk for investors this
means they have to rethink the way they
manage risk bonds from governments and
corporations with high credit ratings
have for years played the role of
stabilizers meaning assets that hold up
or even rise in price when stock prices
go down but since they aren't doing that
investors aren't able to use them to
hedge or reduce their losses from the
stock sell-off investors would also
typically put money into savings
vehicles during times of market stress
like this but with inflation running at
seven and a half percent and savings in
money market accounts paying next to
nothing holding cash effectively means
you're losing money when inflation rises
at seven and a half percent what costs a
thousand dollars today
a thousand seventy five dollars next
year so if your one thousand dollars is
still worth a thousand dollars a year
from now
you've lost seventy five dollars the
only asset class that has really held up
during this current sell-off has been
commodities and commodities historically
have been one of the riskiest
investments in all of finance this new
environment has many rethinking the
traditional investment portfolio of 60
stocks and 40 percent bonds professional
investors have started doing this
already moving money out of bonds and
into things like futures private equity
and hedge fund investments those haven't
performed well either and importantly
they haven't shown themselves to move in
the opposite direction of stock prices
the way bonds had for years in this
environment there really hasn't been
anywhere to hide from falling prices
with traditionally safe assets also
losing value when the market is risk off
the only option may be to put money in
different assets that have historically
been pretty volatile and hope for the
best
if you enjoyed this video hit the like
button if you're interested in markets
subscribe to keep up with my latest
as the great andre 3000 said
wealth is the word rich is around the
corner from the curb
see you next time